I think a good sommelier is like a good
detective people look often make
comments or initial disclosures about
the kind of wines are looking for but I
think if you're if you're a good someone
you really have to take the time to
drill down deeper and ask a lot of
questions to really get an understanding
of the kind of wine that people tend to
prefer or where they're willing to head
a lot of times guests will come in and
they'll say oh I want to try something
totally new and taught you know really
kind of different kind of wine so for me
that's not always easy because I don't I
haven't drank with them before so I
don't know what kind of ones they
normally drink so there's a lot of wine
out there and and some people have a
little bit more commitment to that idea
I think people really want to be
adventurous with wine but you've got to
be careful because a lot of times not
everybody's threshold of adventurism is
the same so asking a lot of questions is
a big part of it and not only just about
the style of wine and the you know the
flavor profile of wines but I think the
budget is is a big part of it too and
it's always the awkward point in a
discussion with a guest I think that
people get nervous about talking about
their price point or their budget which
is it shouldn't be that way I mean you
know I think that there's an old
mentality about the way some ways are
and this whole thing that they're gonna
judge you or that they're gonna try and
take your money I mean yeah they're in
some ways they're salesmen but but I
think a good sommelier never wants to
put someone out of their comfort zone
with the with the wine that they're
gonna drink and I think being upfront
about a budget is something that makes
our life easier because if if some of
these are recommending wines we may
recommend a certain type of wine with
many different you know price points but
if you give a budget right from the
beginning we can kind of go you know
horizontally within that budget and give
you a lot more great options in that in
that sweet spot so there's a lot of ways
to do it I think it's always awkward cuz
you don't know if somebody's on the
first date and you know you don't want
to embarrass somebody you know who's
selecting the wine so I think you know
if you're looking at a wine list and you
can kind of point out a wine that's in a
particular price range that can be a
good way to indicate some way what
you're looking to do but I think being
comfortable with the idea of a solely a
and and then learning to trust them I
think is important not every simile I
guess is completely trustworthy but
there's more and more coming along I
think the
the culture is changing and there's a
lot of opportunity to learn from someone
when you're explaining the kind of wine
that you want to have to so many I think
remembering the kind of wine you had is
important I mean nowadays with
smartphones it's so easy like just
snapping a picture of a label and
keeping it on your phone it inevitably
when people are able to do that even if
I don't have that wine on the list
I know wines that are similar in style
of that so I'm really able to work
within that realm but remembering a
grape varietal that was in it or
remembering you know region it was from
that makes it easier but if that doesn't
work then being able to describe the
flavor profiles is can be difficult and
I think it's a perception thing and
that's the problem like somebody saying
you know I want about it bottle of wine
that's kind of full-bodied but not too
fruity and like those type of keywords I
think help the conversation flow so
trying to remember you know the
experiences you had with that wine and
the things that you tasted or the
tactile experience breaking it down more
particularly as opposed to having it be
you know vague I think that's the best
way more specific details that you can
remember about a one the easier it's
gonna be to get a great bottle and I
think as a guest you're gonna learn more
about wine the more you do that I think
you know it's technology is making that
easier so relying on things like your
smartphone or wine apps or you know
other forms of social media to kind of
learn about what and that really helps